inflation in the united states is at a
40-year high but the u.s dollar isn't
paying attention it continues to rip
higher and higher against a relative
basket of other fiat currencies just
today we can see that the u.s dollar is
up more than one percent and as dylan
leclair points out these are absolutely
massive moves against other major global
currencies the euro continues to suffer
and now one euro is less than one dollar
for the first time in nearly 20 years
but it's not just the euro we also see
that the yen is taking it on the chin as
well as charlie bolillo points out euro
is at its lowest level since 2002 and
the yen is at its lowest level since
1998. these are two of the largest
components of the us dollar index which
is now at a 20-year high
and if we go and we take a look what the
hell is going on in japan we can see
that japan has chosen to sacrifice its
currency to maintain pegging bond yields
via yield curve control
as we continue to watch the global
economy work through the complexity from
loose monetary policy supply chain
disruptions and geopolitical conflict
currencies some of them will strengthen
and some of them will weaken
but the u.s dollar continues to reign
supreme
people around the world want dollars in
times of chaos and uncertainty the u.s
dollar index is at a 20-year high and
the dollars destroying the euro the yen
and many other major global currencies
the u.s dollar and the u.s economy may
be living through a 40-year high in
inflation but that's not stopping
billions of people around the world from
seeking out and holding us dollars at
the end of the day that u.s dollar index
it's a relative comparison and if you
don't like fiat currencies you have to
at least admit the us dollar is the best
of the basket of bad currencies
and that's okay because there are still
billions and billions of people that
benefit from holding dollars in this
exact moment that may change over the
long run maybe we will transition to a
bitcoin based system or some other type
of non-fiat system
but today right now the data is very
clear
the us dollar is stronger than it's been
in 20 years against other major fiat
currencies
and it doesn't look like that's going to
change anytime soon